GOOD NEWS IS, BRET.
>> Bret: THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONED IT AT EVERY
CAMPAIGN STOP AND HAS MADE IT
ONE OF THE MAJOR ISSUES OF THE
ELECTION SEASON, THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANT CARAVANS
HEADING TOWARDS THE U.S. HUD AND
BORDEN.
TONIGHT CATHERINE HERRIDGE TALKS
EXCLUSIVELY WITH HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN, WHO IS TRAVELING IN
THOSE CARAVANS AND HOW THEY ARE
BEING ORGANIZED, FINANCED, AND
MANAGED.
>> WE ABSOLUTELY SEE PEOPLE FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST, FROM SOUTHEAST
ASIA, FROM OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD.
THESE ARE NOT JUST FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA.
SPEAK WITH HUNDREDS OF MIGRANTS
ARRIVING AT MEXICO CITY, SEVERAL
HUNDRED MILES AWAY FROM THE U.S.
BORDER, THE U.S. HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY TOLD FOX NEWS
THERE IS INTELLIGENCE THAT
CARAVANS AND THE LIMITED NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS FROM OUTSIDE THE
REGION.
>> WE DON'T ALWAYS KNOW EXACTLY
WHO THEY ARE.
WE CAN TELL YOU WE STOPPED 3,000
PEOPLE LAST YEAR AT THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER WHO HAD
PATTERNS OF TRAVEL SIMILAR TO A
TERRORIST.
WE CALL THESE SPECIAL INTEREST
ALIENS.
>> DHS IS HEARING REGIONAL
CONCERN FROM REGIONAL PARTNERS.
>> THE PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION
OF THESE CARAVANS, THEY ARE NOT
ORGANIC, IF YOU WELL.
THEY ARE ORGANIZED, FINANCED.
>> NIELSEN ALSO ECHOED EARNINGS
AT THE MOST VULNERABLE ARE
PUSHED AHEAD TO FRUSTRATE BORDER
POLICE AND THE MILITARY.
>> THEY DO NOT -- THEY ARE BEING
USED AS BARRIERS AT THE FRONT OF
SOME OF THESE CARAVANS.
THE OTHER CARAVANS COMING UP ARE
MOSTLY SINGLE MALES.
>> WHAT I SAW IT AS A HIGH LEVEL
OF ORGANIZATION.
>> LATIN AMERICAN SPECIALIST
JUST A FEW MEYER ON THE GROUND
WITH GUATEMALAN INTELLIGENCE TEN
DAYS AGO SAY SOME CARAVANS
OPERATE IN A MILITARY FASHION.
>> WE SAW THE ADVANCE PARTY OF A
SECOND CARAVAN ARRIVING 48 HOURS
BEFORE THE MAIN BODY.
THEY WERE JUST WAITING AT THE
BORDER AND THEY WERE
COMMUNICATING, SECURITY WAS AT
THE BORDER.
>> DEMOCRATS AND SOME
REPUBLICANS ACCUSED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FEARMONGERING
OVER THE CARAVANS.
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA